all right so now is the moment of truth
the first time that you plug it in what
you're looking for is hopefully no smoke
I laugh because it's funny because one
time I had smoke and I ruined everything
go ahead and plug everything in and
basically what we're gonna do first is
we're gonna do a quick setting on the
board that's why I'm like so close to
this board hopefully I'll be able to
show it cuz the back the back light is
super bright but when you plug it in
you'll there are a couple little
settings that I want to show you before
we like zoom out and go to the remote
control in the hole calibration process
so anyway I'm gonna go ahead and plug it
in and I'll show you some things on the
screen because it's just kind of hard to
show the screen ok so sorry I hate to
cut that so I could get some proper
lighting here it's really hard to
capture this thing with the backlight
anyway when you get here I'm gonna show
you a few things that you need to see in
the menu that way I never have to show
the menu part again I'll just tell you
what to do so the first thing you need
to do is set up the motor orientation so
this board is capable of a bunch of
different orientations so you have to
pick one so first you'll hit the menu
button and then scroll down to we're
looking for load motors motor layout go
ahead and hit enter and mine's already
on the X mode but you'll probably be
like right at the top or something so
you want to come down to quadcopter X
mode because ours is in the shape of an
X right as it moves forward once you're
there go ahead hit enter are you sure
yes and then you're all set so now you
can go back but actually while you're
here you can see just take note that
basically over in your top left is motor
one motor twos top right three is bottom
bottom right four is bottom left and
then also note the direction they're
supposed to spin motors one in three
spin clockwise two and four counter
clockwise okay so anyways we'll go back
and really at this point you're ready
just to calibrate but I do want to show
one more thing and that would be go to
the menu and we're gonna look for if you
screw up enough factory reset just take
note that it exists and then I think
sorry I bumped
the receiver test go ahead hit enter
there and right now there's no signal
because my receivers not even on but
later these will be like ranges between
0 and 100 so what you can do is if your
board is an aren't arming for whatever
reason or it's being weird or doing
something you don't expect you can go
here and like test the actual sticks so
as you move them you can see the values
updating on the screen and that's
actually really useful I use that to
figure out why my I couldn't figure out
why my board wasn't arming the first
time and it turns out rudder was
reversed so anyways we'll go ahead and
go back and I'm gonna move the camera
back up now and show you guys the
process for calibrating the esc s but
when I say I'm pressing motor or buttons
one in four it's this button here in
this button here you're just pressing
home so turning on the transmitter
throttle to full coming over to the
power this is kind of hard so I'm trying
to film this and then do this at the
same time and probably not shock myself
would be nice but whatever connect
coming over here and then to the minimum
okay conformational standing stuff let
go and you're good to go
so what's happened is they are now
calibrated and you're good to go now you
have a couple of choices here you could
probably get on the board but i really
suggest more likely that you turn
everything off unplug the quad and ree
plug it back in
you
let's try now there we go okay so I
guess you have to have the transmitter
on first so now what you're gonna do is
check the esc so let's go ahead just
give it a little bit of throttle enough
to make it spin and stop basically again
you're making sure motors 1 & 3 spin
clockwise and 2 & 4 spin
counterclockwise just check each of them
and make sure that is the case you
should even be able to tell in the video
that that's working although motor 3
doesn't look like it in the video but it
is spinning clockwise anyway
now a prize ok so once you have all that
set the only other thing I would
recommend is you do go into the
transmitter thing where you could see
the actual sensor tests you know and
make sure that the directions of your
stakes are what you might expect right
so negative is to the left and positive
to the right and positive is up negative
down and so on make sure that's correct
and then probably to flip them actually
use you flip them in your transmitter
not on the board or anything like that
to arm the board it is down into the
right so disarm the board down into the
left okay keep that in mind once you've
got to this point you're probably ready
to put on propellers so that's what
we're gonna be talking about in the next
tutorial is just putting on the
propellers and actually taking this
thing off and all that